so I had a few other questions one of
the ones that popped up dude said what's
the best way to protect yourself I'm
assuming from her stepping out how to
dominate the situation and be able to
move on quickly to the next one I'll
take this in two questions so what's the
best way to protect
yourself what is the best way to protect
yourself from a woman stepping out on
you you really can't you really can't uh
there's no like there's death and taxes
I can assure you of death of ta death
and taxes let's use the word
probabilities um you know the word that
I've heard George gamon use a lot let's
use probabilities there's probabilities
if you're a bum if you're incompetent if
you're insignificant if you can't hold a
job if you're like if you do nothing but
sit around and watch sports 247 with
Cheeto dust on your clothes getting fat
doing nothing with her or the kids or
any of that stuff and she improves she
becomes uh like a better version of
herself she's sexy you know she's lost
all the baby weight uh she now has a job
of her own she's making loads of money
making more money than you perhaps women
will untie the N okay so the probability
is high if she is better than you you
know if she can do better than you if
she has options right so there's that
too like um I've seen miserable people
stay together in a marriage um and she
won't leave the guy because she's just a
wreck she's just a wreck she's not
good-look she's just a slob out of shape
uh unattractive like she's not going to
do better than the guy that's you know
locking himself in a bedroom depressed
all the time right because she has to
have options you know she just can't
leave you know she's got to have options
um so there's that uh the second part to
that is so sorry let's finish up with
the probabilities so be the best version
of yourself that's all that it boils
down to be as influential as competent
uh have good game make lots of money uh
you know have an interesting life have a
good social network um you know
basically men want to be you and women
want to bang you um you put yourself in
that position you can hit the road
running right um even if you have chosen
to be monogamous to her and only be with
her and she steps out on you yeah it's
going to hurt you for a little bit but
in a week or two go find a couple 25y
old twins tie them up in your bedroom
and have some fun right uh reind duge uh
that's how you move on quickly so this
question was how to dominate the
situation be able to move on quickly to
the next one it's just having options
and the only way that you're going to
have options and be able to move on is
if you're a top shelf guy because then
you look at it like dummy and then you
move on right because you're a topshelf
guy maybe she got duped by some loser
maybe she thought the other guy was
better than you and he turned out to be
married or something like that who the
hell knows does it matter no none of
those things
matter um so next guy said it's a very
relatable topic because cheating from a
trusted woman demolishes a man's ego
absolutely and given the state endangers
his life so so women can manipulate the
state so I'm going to be talking
tomorrow about Brian Johnson's $9
million lawsuit again I mentioned this
at the start it's on the entrepreneurs
and cars Channel be on it live at 10:30
talking about that a little bit uh most
men in the west don't know what's at
stake your idea of Love of a mate and
ability to love you have no idea most
guys have no idea most guys are plugged
in betas all drunk on the Kool-Aid happy
wife happy life you know till death
through was part I love her she touched
my peee she's never going to leave me
sort of thing most guys are like their
heads buried in the sand and then your
freedom and your properties and that's
what women cheating will do to
you right that's what they'll
do the there's there's women today that
were married to topshelf men that are
getting alimony that even though they're
with a new guy that they love and they
want to marry they won't marry them
because they're getting more money in
alimony being unmarried so as soon as
they marry the new guy they lose that
alimony in some cases it's $2,000
$40,000 a month why would they give up
20 to $40,000 a month or more to marry
some guy that they happen to like a lot
when he can't provide her that monthly
income it's heinous it's heinous it's
evil that women can do that right but
that's family law that's how it
works um is it possible to keep the
relationship alive when a partner cheats
but apolog does afterwards that's a yes
or no answer I'm going to say no if a
woman steps out because it's betrayal
I'm going to say yes if a man cheats
because it can just be exercise unless
he falls in love with her and starts
treating her uh like a girlfriend uh you
know like a wife taking
vacations um the key thing that usually
causes problems is if
she's biblically embarrassed random
woman um I don't know if you guys saw
Vikings right but there was a scene
where Ragnar lothbrook ends up going to
another town bangs this chick this
Prince this princess or whatever um you
know she basically rapes him essentially
but anyway bangs her she ends up getting
pregnant he doesn't know he leaves uh
goes back to uh was it katakat or
whatever to his um to his blonde wife
and you know this woman shows up later
with his baby uh the embarrassment is
something that women can't deal so you
can't embarrass her right don't bring
home a disease don't embarrass her uh
don't don't treat her like a girlfriend
those are usually the main things it's
just treat it like excise treat it like
variety that's it um so some women don't
like that fine you know that's a
boundary that they set if they if they
want to bounce on a good guy that's you
know stepped out and still loves you and
wants to maintain something that's fine
for them you know they can do it um I
don't think men should take women back
if they step out I think that the
Betrayal uh once you understand what it
is and the significance of it is too
much to ever get over again uh I've seen
people try to do it I think I tried to
do it at least once um it never works
out it never works out so you know that
old notion that comes from um you know
the red pill where they say um you know
never never take an X back it's like uh
you know going to the curb and like uh
you know rumaging through your garbage
pile sort of thing people see you do it
it never works and you think has value
really doesn't have any value because
you can always do better like there's so
many other women out there um that will
see you as your best option that will
lust for you that will have genuine
burning desire um continuously you know
without any phase um so there's that
uh how to set boundaries with stuff like
male friends work friends girls night
out without being controlling possessive
so this is something that you have to
deal with early on you can't deal with
this I mean here's you know here's a big
problem people guys will go through five
10 years of a relationship things aren't
going well they come to my [__] and
they're like oh she's got male friends
oh she goes out for dinner with work
with a work husband oh she's going to
Vegas for girls night you know like
weekend or she's going out like every
you know couple months for girls night
out or some stuff and getting all
dressed up huh I'm starting to
understand what's going on how do I
correct this Behavior it's very hard
you're going to have a hard time setting
boundaries with a chick that's walked
all over you for 5 to 10 years and you
all of a sudden want to do like well I
don't take women seriously that have
male friends very easy to do when you're
dating if you're spinning plates you
know you're looking for a girlfriend
let's say the strategy really is date a
bunch of women simultaneously in a nom
monogamous fashion have your fun let the
cream rise to the top the cream will be
the one that comes to you or the ones
that come to you and say Rich where do
we stand I dig your Vibe I want to claim
you I don't want to share you where's
this going blah blah blah uh that's when
you do the awesome um but I have to tell
you this I can't take a chick seriously
that keeps male friends around I mean
you know I can't have you going out to
dinner with your ex- fiance from two
years ago because you're just friends
right because nobody [__] more wives
and girlfriends then he's just a friend
so yeah you need to set those boundaries
you need to set the boundaries around uh
girls night out you know stuff like that
girls night turn it into a coffee in the
morning go out with your girl friends
and have your coffee but if your chick
wants to go to Vegas or Nashville or
Miami for a weekend or Cancun or Aiza or
mikinos you know with her friends on a
trip then all you have to do is say
early on I don't take women seriously
that you know go out with girlfriends
and behave like they're single I just
don't I'm I'm you know like you want to
claim me you want a relationship with me
then there's this boundary around this
relationship to preserve it and protect
it I can't have you betraying me you
know it's about the extent of what you
need to say that's it but as far as you
know dealing with them after you've been
together for a while very hard to do so
I wish you luck with that it's it's
generally probably falling apart anyway
so when you start setting boundaries
she's not going to like it um it's it's
not often that you know women will be
like well I've walked all over this guy
for seven years but all of a sudden he
you know he doesn't want me to have male
friends or I can't have a work husband
or I can't go to Vegas you know with my
friends like once a year or some [__]
like that you think she's going to
modify her behavior for that guy that
she's seen as a
all of a sudden he's trying to become an
alpha male no probably not going to
happen um another one I got over here is
is an open relationship so this is all
in the description of the video by the
way is an open relationship marriage
situation okay after a cheating or
betrayal um what usually ends up
happening when these women open up the
marriage or the relationship after
cheating is they just go around [__]
a bunch of dudes and this guy now thinks
that he's going to have some action but
it's very hard for guys to get laid see
this is what people don't understand
they're like well if men can do it why
can't women do it too how hard is it for
a guy to get laid it's not easy it's not
you have to you have to be captivating
you have to have game you have like you
have to know something right whereas
women she could literally walk up to any
dude say I'm horny let's bang and the
vast majority be like all right where
right it's very very easy for women it's
very difficult for guys especially dorks
that have been betrayed by a woman
they're self-confident you know is now
in the toilet um they don't have a
strong opinion of themselves she's now
got like a hul pass to do whatever the
hell she wants so she's running around
getting a train run on her you're
probably not even sleeping with her
anymore and you're just the guy paying
all the bills maybe babysitting the kids
while she goes out Sala dancing with her
friends banging Jorge in the bathroom or
something like that right he goes on to
say as me means of a strategy of working
things out or just better to just be
finished yeah just be finished now if
you have kids I
mean it's up to you like I'll be
absolutely honest with you it's it's
terrible when parents uh part ways and
the kids uh don't have access to both
parents on a very frequent basis so some
people stay together for the kids uh and
then they'll just have um you know a
boyfriend and you know he'll have a
girlfriend sort of thing and they just
sort of like share the house that's one
way that I've seen some people do it
having children together is a reasoning
example to try and work things out um
look not if she's banging other dudes
because again women
can't I mean they do it it's not that
they can't do it but women can't indis
indiscriminately share their bodies with
loads of dudes a little piece of her
soul dies off when she does this right
um it's just not good it's not good
right you know people get mad at me they
say well Rich well you encourage guys to
indulge well yeah women aren't pure
anymore right what you I'm gonna tell
guys to sit around and you know pick
their nose and not do anything and not
indulge or not participate women have
been doing it forever right now you can
decide what you want to do if you want
to find somebody you know young and pure
if you want to have a family there's
lots of options you know to contemp and
stuff like that but no you know do this
guy's point about an open relationship
or an open marriage I mean it's usually
her going out on the weekend banging
Alphas while you're sitting around doing
nothing watching sports or playing video
games or something I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the fulllength podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out